La alianza entre Estados Unidos y los países
europeos no vive su mejor momento.
Donald Trump ha llegado como un vendaval y ha puesto a la pareja
al borde de la separación.
Lo hemos visto con el acuerdo de París,
y
también con la posición de Trump
hacia la OTAN, la organización militar más
poderosa de todos los tiempos.
Precisamente hoy vamos a fijarnos en esta
organización.
¿Qué está pasando con la OTAN?
¿Por qué Donald Trump la critica tanto?
¿Cuál es su importancia y su futuro?
Atentos a este vídeo, pero antes tomemos
un poco de perspectiva.
Al poco de terminar la II Guerra Mundial,
la Organización del Tratado del Atlántico
Norte, la OTAN, se puso en marcha.
Concretamente nació en 1949 con una misión
y un objetivo muy claros: contener, frenar
y en su caso, vencer, militarmente a la Unión
Soviética.
(Acababa de empezar, amigos, la Guerra Fría
y la tensión en el ambiente era enorme.
Se acaba de vivir el bloqueo de Berlín y
el Partido Comunista checo había tomado completamente
el control con un golpe de estado).
En ese momento, amigos, nadie descartaba ningún
escenario, ni siquiera el de la guerra.
Y, ojo, pensemos en el contexto histórico:
el mundo acababa de vivir la segunda guerra
mundial, Europa estaba destruida y la desconfianza
y el odio entre bandos ideológicos era casi
total.
La verdad, pensar en una guerra no resultaba
nada extraño.
Pues bien, ese es el contexto bajo el que
se funda la OTAN, integrada en un primer momento
por Estados Unidos, Canadá y 10 países europeos:
Francia, Reino Unido, Italia, Bélgica, Holanda,
Luxemburgo, Dinamarca, Noruega, Islandia y
Portugal.
Pocos años después, además, se uniría
la República Federal Alemana, es decir, la
Alemania Occidental.
Pues bien, el planteamiento esencial de la alianza, su
espíritu, pasa por unir fuerzas, si un país
miembro es atacado, se considera que todos
los países miembros son atacados.
Algo así como el lema de los Mosqueteros
de Alejandro Dumas:
Claro que, con muchos matices y letra pequeña,
luego lo veremos.
Sin embargo, en 1991 todo cambió.
La caída de la Unión Soviética dejó a
la OTAN sin una misión clara
¿Si el enemigo desaparece qué sentido tiene
la alianza?
Esa es una pregunta que muchos se hicieron
en aquel entonces y que aún hoy muchas personas
se hacen.
Pero, esperad un momento, porque contra todo
pronóstico es a partir de ese momento, de
la desaparición de la Unión Soviética cuando
más actividad comienza a tener esta organización.
(De hecho, la primera intervención militar
de la OTAN se produjo en los 90 durante la
Guerra de Bosnia, y desde entonces sus operaciones
han sido relativamente frecuentes: Serbia,
Kosovo, Afganistán, Libia, el control del
báltico, las operaciones contra la piratería
en el Océano Índico y recientemente el apoyo
a la lucha contra el ISIS)
También ha sido en este periodo, amigos,
cuando más países nuevos se han sumado al
club.
Desde que se pusiera en marcha la OTAN, la
incorporación de nuevos países ha sido casi
continua, pero desde 1991 la cosa se aceleró
bastante.
Si en 1949 eran 12 países hoy ya son 28 sus
integrantes, muchos de ellos, por cierto,
países del antiguo Pacto de Varsovia, que
era algo así como la OTAN liderada por la
Unión Soviética.
Algo que, la verdad, no le ha sentado nada
bien a la Rusia de Vladimir Putin.
(De hecho, la guerra de 2008 entre Rusia y
Georgia se debió en gran medida porque este
país del Cáucaso quería integrarse en la
OTAN.
Algo parecido ha ocurrido en Ucrania).
Y, ojo, tras la reciente crisis en Ucrania
y el choque con la Rusia de Vladimir Putin,
la OTAN parece haber pisado el acelerador.
En 2015 realizó las mayores maniobras militares
en años, se movilizaron
a más de 36000 soldados de 30 países diferentes.
También se ha puesto en marcha, en 2016,
una fuerza de acción inmediata compuesta
por unos 5.000 soldados que es capaz de desplegarse
muy rápidamente en prácticamente cualquier
lugar.
(La llamada punta de lanza de la OTAN aglutina
a unos 5.000 soldados que forman parte de
una fuerza de acción rápida más amplia,
compuesta por 40.000.
Para garantizar y coordinar su despliegue,
la Alianza ha creado, desde septiembre de
2014, ocho cuarteles de apoyo, todos en países
de antigua influencia soviética)
Y, en 2017, sin ir más lejos, Estados Unidos,
cumpliendo con una misión de la OTAN está
realizando el mayor despliegue de tropas en
Europa desde la Guerra Fría
Hablamos, amigos, de más de 4000 soldados
y cientos de tanques y vehículos blindados
que hoy están ya desplegados en Europa del
Este con una misión que recuerda mucho a
la etapa inicial de la OTAN: Disuadir a Rusia
de cualquier tentación expansionista.
Sin embargo, a pesar de toda esta actividad
hay bastante dudas sobre el papel de la OTAN
y sobre todo, Estados Unidos no está muy
conforme con el compromiso de sus socios europeos.
Cómo os decía antes, la garantía de defensa
mutua si un país miembro de la OTAN es atacado
no es tan clara como parece.
Fijaos lo que dice el artículo 5, que es
el que regula esta situación:
Incluso el empleo de la fuerza armada….
Es decir, en caso de que un país miembro
sufra un ataque no se obliga al resto a darle
inmediatamente apoyo militar.
Por eso, todos los presidentes de Estados
Unidos desde Harry Truman han aprovechado
su primera asistencia a una reunión de la
OTAN para hacer una interpretación artículo y
comprometerse militarmente.
(Sin embargo, Donald Trump no lo ha hecho.
Se esperaba que lo hiciese en la inauguración
de un monumento a las víctimas del 11S en
Bruselas, donde el pasado 25 de mayo de 2017
asistió a su primera reunión de la OTAN;
los países europeos, de hecho, se lo habían
pedido, la Casa Blanca dijo que lo haría,
pero Trump al final no realizó ningún compromiso.)
Bien, hay analistas a los que esto les parece
muy importante, y lo presentan como uno de
los mayores errores diplomáticos de los últimos
años; otros analistas no le dan tanta importancia;
pero lo cierto es que en Europa ha sentado
muy mal.
(Sobre todo, porque hasta el momento el único
país que ha invocado el artículo 5 ha sido
precisamente Estados Unidos.
Lo hizo tras el 11s y por supuesto recibió
el apoyo inmediato de todos los miembros de
la OTAN.)
El caso es que Trump no quiso brindar su apoyo,
lejos de ello aprovechó su discurso para
recriminar la supuesta falta de compromiso
de sus aliados europeos.
Pero, ojo, este enfado no es sólo de Trump, también
Obama lo compartía.
Así que, la pregunta es: ¿Y por qué en Estados Unidos
están tan enfadados con la OTAN?
Pues básicamente porque afirman que los miembros
europeos de la OTAN no están comprometidos
y no gastan lo suficiente.
(En principio, como regla, los países miembros
de la OTAN tienen el compromiso de gastar
en defensa al menos el 2% de su PIB.
Sin embargo, solo unos pocos países cumplen
este criterio: Reino Unido, Polonia, Estonia,
Grecia, y, por supuesto, Estados Unidos)
El resto están bastante lejos.
Fijaos en lo que le ha dicho James Mattis,
el Secretario de Defensa de Donald Trump,
a los países europeos.
Ahora bien, esperad un momento ¿Quiere decir
esto que los países europeos no gastan en
defensa?
Para NADA.
De hecho, si sumamos los presupuestos militares
de los países europeos miembros de la OTAN
veremos que cada año gastan más de 260.000
millones dólares, es decir, si fuesen un
país, serían el segundo con más gasto militar
sólo tras Estados Unidos.
Vamos, que si hablamos en dinero contante
y sonante no parece que el problema esté
en que el nivel de gasto sea reducido o al
menos no parece que las amenazas que existen
hoy justifiquen un nivel de gasto tan extraordinario.
Sobre todo, si tenemos en cuenta el nuevo
escenario de seguridad y cuales son los nuevos
retos a los que se enfrenta la OTAN. Porque, amigos, ya no vivimos en los tiempos de la URSS.
Digámoslo claro, el mundo ha cambiado, y los retos hoy no son los mismos que los que había en 1960, por
ejemplo.
Hoy los grandes riesgos no se concentran en
la posibilidad de una gran guerra. La destrucción
mutua asegurada, la globalización y el comercio
han reducido mucho ese riesgo.
Hoy las grandes amenazas las encontramos en
el terrorismo, la piratería, las ciberguerras,
ojo muy importante, y también el riesgo de proliferación de armas de destrucción masiva.
¿Tenemos que combatir estos riesgos?
Desde luego, pero es algo, amigos, que no
se consigue con más tanques y más bombarderos.
Luego también tenemos que tener en cuenta que hoy
nos enfrentamos a nueva forma de hacer la
guerra, la conocida como guerra híbrida,
donde los combates no son tan explícitos
como lo eran antes o como salen en las películas.
(Hoy las guerras modernas pasan cada vez más
por apoyar guerrillas y grupos desestabilizadores,
presiones políticas, sanciones económicas,
ciberguerra, injerencia en los procesos electorales,
acciones de inteligencia varias…)
Fijaos en la estrategia de Putin en Rusia,
algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado en otros
vídeos, aquí en VisualPolitik…
Eso sí, todo esto no quiere decir que los
miembros europeos de la OTAN estén haciendo
las cosas bien.
Por un lado, la organización tiene establecido
otro requisito además de la regla del 2%
que es dedicar el 20% del presupuesto a inversión en equipamiento. Esto tiene más sentido
y aquí la mayoría de los países europeos,
que gastan mucho dinero en gastos fijos y
ejércitos con más soldados de los necesarios,
tampoco llegan.
Por otro los países europeos están poco
integrados y manejan sistemas de armas muy
diferentes, lo que incrementa los costes de
producción, mantenimiento y despliegue.
(Fijaos lo que ocurre con los tanques, por
ejemplo.
Estados Unidos opera fundamentalmente un tipo
de tanque, el Abrams, mientras que los países
europeos operan hasta 19 modelos diferentes
de tanques.)
¡Imaginaos que caos supone todo esto a la hora
de realizar un despliegue conjunto!
¡Ni siquiera pueden compartir líneas de
suministro de repuestos!
Y lo mismo ocurre con los aviones, la flota,
etc.
El caso, amigos, es que tal vez la pregunta final sea: ¿Puede la OTAN jugar un papel importante?
Personalmente creo que sí, pero también
creo que tiene que adaptarse a los tiempos
y cambiar su enfoque.
Mi impresión personal es que tenemos que
gastar mejor y compartir recursos, no gastar
más, aunque esto pueda decepcionar a muchos
contratistas militares.
Bueno, y ahora turno para ti, puedes dejarnos tu opinión en esta encuesta.
¿Cuál crees que debe
ser el futuro de la OTAN?
¿Defiendes que los países europeos cumplan
con las exigencias de Estados Unidos?
o ¿Crees por el contrario que la OTAN tiene
que enfocarse a tareas menos relacionada con
la guerra convencional?
¿Crees incluso debe disolverse?
Déjanos también tu opinión en los comentarios y ya sabes,
si este vídeo te ha resultad
interesante dale a like.
Por cierto, si quieres saber quién es el
mayor aliado de Estados Unidos y por qué
Donald Trump ha puesto en riesgo esta amistad
no te pierdas este vídeo:
Un saludo y hasta la próxima!